Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und heute haben wir schon die 42. Ausgabe unserer kleinen Gesprächsreihe hier rund um die Raumfahrt. Und wie schon in der letzten Sendung geht es um ein Thema, was vor allem in Italien geplant und durchgeführt wird. Hier am Essrin, dem Standort für Erdbeobachtungen, nicht nur für Erdbeobachtungen, aber vor allem Erdbeobachtungen. Und nachdem wir in der letzten Folge vor allem über Envisat gesprochen haben, dem sehr erfolgreichen Langzeitprojekt der Erdbeobachtung, der ESA, geht es heute in gewisser Hinsicht um eine Fortsetzung dessen, denn Envisat ist nicht mehr in Betrieb. Der Bedarf für weitere Erdbeobachtungen besteht allerdings und es gibt ein Nachfolgeprojekt namens GMES. Und was es damit auf sich hat, das erklärt uns jetzt Josef Aschbacher. Hallo Josef. Willkommen bei Raumzeit. Du bist hier, wie es so schön heißt, Head of GMES Space Office, also einer Abteilung, die sich explizit genau um GMES kümmert. Was ist da konkret deine Aufgabe?
Meine Aufgabe ist, also GMES vielleicht ganz kurz erläutert, was das bedeutet und was das Programm macht. Das ist ein globales Programm, das sich um die Überwachung der Erde kümmert und hier vor allem im Umwelt- und Sicherheitsbereich. Meine Aufgabe in diesem Projekt, in diesem Programm, ist die Leitung, die Koordination des Programmes innerhalb der ESA durchzuführen, vor allem zu koordinieren mit den Partnern, mit den externen Partnern der Europäischen Kommission, aber auch Eumetsat und anderen Partnern in Europa, um das Programm zu implementieren und hier vor allem den Weltraumbereich des GMES-Programmes zu implementieren. GMES hat ja relativ viele Facetten, hat drei Hauptkomponenten, eine Dienstleistungskomponente, die geleitet wird von der Europäischen Kommission, eine INSITO-Komponente, wie es so schön heißt. INSITO sind alle Messungen, die durchgeführt werden, außerhalb oder nicht von Satelliten, mit Temperaturmessungen, Luft- und Wasserqualitätsmesserungen, andere Daten, die hinzugefügt werden. Und dann haben wir die dritte Komponente, die Weltraumkomponente, und die ist eben jene Komponente, die die ESA implementiert. Und hier ist meine Aufgabe wirklich, die Aktivitäten innerhalb dieser Weltraumkomponente zu koordinieren.
Wie lange bist du schon selber bei der ESA?
Ich bin bei der ESA seit 2001. Ich war vorher bei der Europäischen Kommission. GMES ist in der Europäischen Kommission entwickelt oder definiert worden. Und zwar 1998 in Barveno, auch in Italien, etwas nördlicher von hier am Lago Maggiore. 1998 war kurze Zeit nachdem die Kriege in Ex-Jugoslawien stattgefunden haben und einige Entscheidungsträger in Europa haben gesehen, dass eigentlich es enorm wichtig ist, Informationen zu haben vor der eigenen Haustür. Es war ja damals so, dass zum Beispiel die Information, die aus Amerika beigetragen wurde und geliefert wurde aus amerikanischen Behörden, dass die viel besser war als die Information, die europäische Partner hatten, die Franzosen, die Deutschen, die Italiener und andere. Und das war natürlich bezogen auf, in dem Fall, auf militärische Information. Man hat das zum Anlass genommen, um zu sagen, Europa braucht eigentlich ein Informationssystem, nicht für das Militär, aber um den Umweltzustand der Erde, die Nutzung der Bodenschätze, den Zustand der Atmosphäre, der Landwirtschaft, der Forstwirtschaft einfach besser zu überwachen. Und hat damals das als Anlass genommen, um GMES zu beginnen. Das war damals im Rahmen der Europäischen Kommission. Es war im Rahmen einer Konferenz, wo die Leiter der Weltraumagentur in Europa eingeladen wurden, zu einem Gespräch, zu einem Brainstorming, wie man so schön sagt. Und es wurde nachgedacht, wie kann man die Erdbeobachtung in die nächste Phase bringen, von den derzeitigen Erdbeobachtungssatelliten, die damals aktuell waren. Das war RS1, RS2 und Envisat hat nicht einmal begonnen. Und die Idee war damals, einfach wegzugehen oder sich weiter zu entwickeln von Einzelmissionen in eine Serie von operationellen Satelliten. Im Prinzip eigentlich genau das, was wir in der Meteorologie sehr erfolgreich machen, seit Dekaden, wo wir mit MeteorSat-1 in den 70er Jahren angefangen haben, Messungen durchzuführen, die natürlich verbunden wurden mit anderen Messungen, Lufttemperatur, Druck, Niederschläge und so weiter. Diese Messungen wurden kombiniert mit Modellrechnungen, numerische Wettermodelle, die dann zur Wetter- vorhersage am Abend führen, die man im Fernsehen, im Radio und so weiter bekommt. Das Prinzip ist genau das Gleiche. Man will eigentlich mit GMES so was wie in der Meteorologie aufbauen. Ein operationelles System, bestehend aus Satellitenaufnahmen, anderen Messungen, Modellen, die dann zu Informationen führen, die für Entscheidungsträger einfach wichtig sind, um Informationen zu bekommen, sowohl für politische Entscheidungen, strategische Entscheidungen, aber auch für den täglichen Nutzen einfach von Bedeutung sind.
Hier wird schon deutlich, dass das GMES ein bisschen anders aufgehängt ist als die meisten anderen Raumfahrtmissionen, die die ESA so bisher auch durchgeführt hat. Du hast gesagt, du warst vorher auch bei der EU, aber da war ja sicherlich nicht Raumfahrt dein Kernthema oder gab es da auch schon immer eine Division?
Es war Raumfahrt mein Kernthema. Ich war damals am sogenannten Institut für Raumfahrtanwendungen in Ispra. Die Europäische Kommission hat ein relativ großes Forschungszentrum in Norditalien. Man weiß das eigentlich nicht, weil man mit der Europäischen Kommission immer Brüssel verbindet, aber in Ispra gibt es ein sehr großes Zentrum mit 2000 Leuten in etwa, die meistens Wissenschaftler und Forscher sind und hier gab es, das gibt es heute nicht mehr, gab es ein Institut für Raumfahrtanwendungen und ich war in diesem Institut tätig als Assistent des Direktors. Der Direktor übrigens ist Deutscher Professor Winter, der mittlerweile in Pension ist, aber damals Direktor war und meine Ausbildung ist eigentlich eine metrologische Ausbildung, eine fachliche Ausbildung in der Fernerkundung und dort hat die Europäische Kommission seit sehr vielen Jahren schon im Bereich Weltraum gearbeitet.
Warum engagiert sich die EU da jetzt konkret und warum überlässt man das nicht den Raumfahrtagenturen an der Stelle?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage und das hat diese Überlegungen oder diese Diskussion hat auch zu einer Umorientierung innerhalb der EU geführt. Das Institut für Weltraumanwendungen, von dem ich gerade gesprochen habe, gibt es heute nicht mehr und eine Überlegung war genau jene, die du gerade ansprichst, dass wir in Europa die Europäische Weltraumbehörde haben, die eben mit Weltraumfragen sich beschäftigt. Die EU hat sich dann darauf konzentriert, um eben die Anwendungen zu unterstützen und unterstreichen. Nämlich wie werden Weltraumdaten verwendet für verschiedene Anwendungen, zum Beispiel in der Landwirtschaft, zum Beispiel in der Forstwirtschaft, zum Beispiel im Katastrophenschutz und ähnlichen Anwendungen. Und das ist jetzt der Ausgangspunkt auch des Instituts in ISPRA, das ja nach wie vor existiert, um eben alle möglichen Technologien zu verwenden, um die europäische Politik zu unterstützen. Und es hat insofern natürlich eine kleine Änderung stattgefunden, dass insofern, dass die Aktivitäten, die vorher oder damals mehr auf Raumfahrt ausgerichtet waren, jetzt von der ESA, der europäischen Weltraumbehörde, übernommen werden.
Du selbst hast gesagt, du bist Meteorologe, also hast du auch Meteorologie studiert?
Ich habe Meteorologie studiert in Innsbruck, Universität Innsbruck. Das ist eine sehr gute Universität für Meteorologie und das Institut hat auch als Besonderheit eine Fachrichtung Fernerkundung, die in Österreich relativ gut ist und von der es nur sehr wenige gibt. Österreich ist ein kleines Land und eine der Hauptzweige im Institut für Meteorologie in Innsbruck war auch die Fernerkundungsmetheorologie, die mich interessiert hat und in der ich sowohl Diplomarbeit als auch die Situation gemacht habe. Von der Fernerkundungsmethoden in der Metrologie bin ich dann direkt zur europäischen Weltraumbehörde gekommen und zu diesen Projekten und Programmen, in denen ich heute tätig bin, vor allem eben GMES, also dieses Projekt, das sich wirklich auf europäischer Ebene um die Anwendung von Fernerkundungsdaten für verschiedene Bereiche kümmert.
Also obwohl es jetzt da sozusagen die Erkenntnis gab, dass Raumfahrtbezogenes vielleicht besser auch bei den Raumfahrt- agenturen schwerpunktmäßig untergebracht ist, ist es trotzdem jetzt insofern ein Novum, dass man jetzt hier mit GMES, also ausgeschrieben heißt es ja Global Monitoring for Environment and Security, also es gibt ja sowohl den reinen Umweltaspekt als eben auch den weitergefassten Sicherheitsaspekt, sich eigentlich auf eine ganz neue Balance ergibt von von beteiligten Gruppierungen. Gab es sowas Ähnliches schon mal in irgendeiner Form oder ist es wirklich ein komplett neuer Ansatz?
Das ist ein relativ neuer Ansatz. Es gibt natürlich Umwelt-Satelliten. Wir haben vorhin über Envisat gesprochen. Envisat war der europäische Satellit, der sich um Messungen bemüht im Umweltbereich. In gewisser Weise führt GMES diese Messungen weiter, die über Envisat aufgebaut wurden und den Nutzerkreis, der dadurch aufgebaut wurde. Aber GMES hat eine andere Dimension angenommen, nicht nur in der Komplexität, aber auch in der Art und Weise, wie das Projekt aufgebaut ist. Zum Beispiel die ESA-Satelliten, die wir vorher hatten, ERS-1, ERS-2 und Envisat, waren Wissenschaftsmissionen oder quasi voroperationelle Missionen. Also der Hauptzweck war, neue Technologie, neue Instrumente zu entwickeln, zu testen, neue Auswertungsalgorithmen zu entwickeln und dadurch neue Anwendungen zu entdecken. Also einfach die klassische Forschung, wie man sich eigentlich vorstellt. Das ist sehr, sehr erfolgreich gemacht worden, aber irgendwann hat man sich damals, wie gesagt, in Barveno überlegt, man muss eigentlich von der Forschung auch einen nächsten Schritt machen und zwar in die operationelle Anwendung. Und das ist genau was GMES eben macht, dass wir aus der Forschung, mit all diesen Ergebnissen und all der Informationen, die wir bekommen aus Envisat, aus ERS in den vergangenen Jahren, dass wir dieses System umwandeln oder aufbauen in ein volles operationelles System. Und es gibt hier einige Unterschiede zwischen den Sentinel.
Also den Begriff operationelles System sollte man vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen aufdröseln. Gemeint ist damit, dass man, also ich hatte das schon im Gespräch mit Michael Rast, im Envisat das klar wurde, man hatte zwar die Forschung im Wesentlichen im Blick, auch bei der Spezifikation und man hat im Wesentlichen auch alle Instrumente erst mal am wissenschaftlichen Hunger ausgerichtet, dann aber festgestellt, dass die Daten nicht nur kontinuierlich fließen, sondern auch in vielen Bereichen so viel Aussagekraft haben, dass sie eben, wenn man sie permanent weiterreicht, eben an der Stelle ganz neue Mechanismen erlauben, sowohl in der Industrie, in der kommerziellen Nutzung, aber eben auch in der politischen Dimension, weil Erkenntnisse über die Erdveränderung, nicht nur wegen des Klimawandels, sondern eben aus vielen anderen Gründen heraus eben auch für die Politik natürlich wichtiger Nährboden sind, um zukünftige Was ist das für eine wichtige Entscheidung zu beeinflussen?
Genau, das ist absolut richtig und das ist genau auch die Motivation, warum GMES so entwickelt wurde, wie es entwickelt wurde. Nehmen wir wiederum das Beispiel Envisat, das wir gerade angesprochen haben. Envisat war ein enorm erfolgreicher Satellit, der in sehr vielen Bereichen einfach fantastische Messungen gebracht hat, die zu sehr wichtigen wissenschaftlichen Ergebnissen geführt haben. Es gibt eine große Anzahl, die man hier erwähnen könnte. GMES hat natürlich davon profitiert, will aber jetzt diese wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisse und diese Methoden, die dabei entwickelt wurden, überführen in operationelle Anwendungen. So was heißt das? Operationell in diesem Sinne heißt, dass es Information sein wird, die einfach im täglichen Leben gebraucht wird, die für den einzelnen Bürger wichtig ist zu haben oder besser informiert zu sein. Nehmen wir ein Beispiel. Envisat hat dazu geführt, mit den Atmosphärensensoren gewisse Algorithmen zu entwickeln, um Luftqualitätsmessungen durchzuführen. In den meisten Bereichen hat das dazu geführt, dass einfach Pilotdienstleistungen entwickelt wurden, aber nicht unbedingt dazu geführt haben, dass sie voll operationell eingesetzt werden. Zum Beispiel, was wir in GMES versuchen, ist eben durch kontinuierliche Messungen, die auch häufiger aufgemacht werden, als wie zum Beispiel durch Envisat, durch kontinuierliche Messungen gewisse Informationen täglich angeboten wird.
Zum Wetter auf jeden Fall.
Wetter wird natürlich bereits angeboten, das wird durch die Wetter-Satelliten natürlich mit Daten beliefert. Im GMES-Bereich macht man eigentlich nichts anderes als im Wetterbereich, im meteorologischen Bereich, aber in anderen Domänen, in anderen Disziplinen. Zum Beispiel Luftqualität, um nur ein Beispiel herauszuleuchten. Es gibt in London eine Dienstleistung, die man über Internet, über Mobiltelefon, über iPhone, über Android-Telefone abrufen kann, wo man täglich in London in einem Straßenzug die Luftqualität bekommt, wie sie aktuell ist, mit einer Vorhersage, wie die nächsten zwei bis drei Tage sich entwickeln werden.
Mit der Auflösung eines Straßenzuges?
In der Auflösung eines Straßenzuges. Was natürlich gemacht wird, ist, dass ein Teil der Information von Satelliten kommt, die größere Auflösung, aber dann verfeinert wird mit Punktmessungen, die bereits in der Stadt vorhanden sind. Das wird eingebaut in Modelle, verknüpft mit meteorologischen Modellen. Das führt zu einer Vorhersage der Konzentration von NOX zum Beispiel für die nächsten ein, zwei, drei Tage. Das ist insofern wichtig, weil dadurch zum Beispiel Leute, die anfällig sind, wissen, ob sie am Nachmittag oder morgen früh in das Zentrum der Stadt gehen können oder sollen, wie groß die Belastung ist. Asthmatiker, aber auch andere Leute, die gesundheitliche Schäden haben oder geschwächt sind, können davon profitieren und durch solche Informationen, die einfach zugänglich ist, ganz einfach abrufen, ob es gut oder schlecht ist, in die Stadt zu gehen.
Und die Politik gewinnt ein Bild darüber, wie sich das auch über die Zeit so entwickelt, ob es schlimmer wird?
Die Politik profitiert natürlich davon, hat die Information, aber auch natürlich einen gesamtgesellschaftlichen Nutzen. Wenn zum Beispiel die Anfälligkeit von Asthmakranken reduziert wird, dann werden die Kosten gesenkt im Gesundheitsbereich und dadurch natürlich eine gewisse Wertschöpfung oder ein gewisser Wert für die Wirtschaft oder die Gesellschaft erzeugt. Andere Beispiele sind Landwirtschaft. In der Landwirtschaft gibt es ja sehr oft und seit langem schon die Möglichkeit, die Erntevorhersagen mit Hilfe von Satelliten durchzuführen. GMES wird genauso dazu beitragen, diese Erntevorhersagen zu verbessern, sowohl in Europa als auch außerhalb. Was natürlich wichtige Information ist für die Politik, aber auch für einzelne kleinere Sektoren. Um einfach abzuschätzen, muss ich mehr Weizen einkaufen für ein gewisses Land, für einen gewissen Teil der Bevölkerung oder kann ich mehr Kartoffeln exportieren, wie wird sich der Markt entwickeln und so weiter.
Wie kann man denn das denn feststellen, dass mehr Kartoffeln wachsen?
Das kann man feststellen. Die Satelliten fliegen ja ständig um die Erde. Machen ständig Aufnahmen. Die Sensoren, die sich auf den Satelliten befinden, Sentinel-2 in dem Fall ist der wichtigste in der Familie der Sentinel-Satelliten, hat Spektralbereiche, die empfindlich sind für die Parameter, auf die man Rückschlüsse machen kann und die verknüpft sind mit Erntevorhersagen.
Mit Bodenqualität oder Luftqualität oder beides?
Das ist Bodenqualität, aber wichtiger noch der Zustand der Pflanze. Ob die Pflanze genug Wasser zur Verfügung hat, ob sie dürrer wird und deshalb der Fruchtertrag geringer sein wird.
Eine Beobachtung der wachsenden Vegetation.
Eine Beobachtung der Pflanze während der Wachstumsphase. Und indem man über die Infrarotkanäle abschätzt, wie gesund die Pflanze ist und wie viel Wasser zur Verfügung steht, kann man auf den erwartenden Ernteertrag Rückschlüsse machen.
Also wenn man sieht, sie sind ohnehin schon so ein bisschen gestresst und dann weiß man aus dem Wettervorhersagen, Dürreperiode steht an und das kurz vor der Ernte, das sieht nicht gut aus.
Genau so ist es ja.
Verstehe. Das heißt, hier kommen eigentlich mehrere Sachen zusammen. Auf der einen Seite geht es um die Fortsetzung der Erdbeobachtung einfach auch für den wissenschaftlichen Nutzen. Das ist also nach wie vor Teil des Ganzen. Es geht jetzt nicht nur darum, eine ganz andere Nutzung der Raumfahrt voranzutreiben, sondern eben auch diesen damals noch eher als Nebenaspekt bewerteten Bereich der permanenten Überwachung, um Daten auf einer zuverlässigen Ebene zu liefern. Also das Wort Dienstleistung ist ja schon gefallen mehrfach. Dienstleistung ist ja nicht unbedingt immer das Erste, was man jetzt mit einem wissenschaftlichen Betrieb assoziieren würde.
Es ist richtig, GMES ist eben darauf ausgerichtet, Dienstleistungen zu erstellen in verschiedenen Bereichen. Es gibt heute fünf große Bereiche, in denen diese Dienstleistungen angeboten werden. Diese Bereiche sind jene, die das System Erde beschreiben, Atmosphäre, Ozeane und Land. Dann gibt es zwei horizontale Domänen. Das eine ist Katastrophenschutz, das andere ist Sicherheit im weiteren Sinne. Und dann gibt es noch eine sechste Disziplin, Klimaschutz oder Klimawandel, der in GMES auch als Dienstleistung angeboten wird. In diesen relativ weiten Bereichen werden dann einzelne Untersektoren und Unterdienstleistungen entwickelt, die jeweils spezifisch darauf ausgerichtet sind, nach den Bedürfnissen der einzelnen Gruppen. Das kann die Forstwirtschaft, die Landwirtschaft, die Fischerei genauso betreffen wie die Schifffahrtsindustrie. Und das ist ein sehr weiter Bereich. Also hier gibt es wirklich Anwendungen, die sehr weit gehen. Sehr wichtig natürlich auch der gesamte Katastrophenschutzbereich. Hier werden Satelliten eingesetzt für Überflutungen zum Beispiel. Es kommt jedes Jahr vor, dass nach der Schneeschmelze und gekoppelt mit starken Regenfällen natürlich die größeren Flüsse in Europa ständig zu Überflutungen führen, die Donau zum Beispiel. Und in einzelnen Ländern ist das Flutvorhersagesystem nicht so gut ausgebildet und hier bilden die Informationen aus den Satelliten einen ganz wichtigen Bereich der Information. Das wird auch verwendet, wenn die Überflutung dann, also diese Daten werden verwendet, um im Fall der Überflutung den Hilfsdiensten Informationen anzubieten, also wo ist überflutet, welche Teiche, welche Dämme sind in Gefahr und später, also wenn das Ereignis vorüber ist, um einfach auch den Schaden abzuschätzen, also welche Art von Landnutzung wurde geschädigt, war das landwirtschaftliches Gebiet, waren das Stadtgebiete, waren das Ackerflächen oder einfach leerstehende Flächen, weil sehr oft natürlich auch nach großen Katastrophen große Schadensforderungen an die Regierungen gemacht werden und die werden zum Teil auch mit Hilfe von Satelliten abgeschätzt, ob die berechtigt sind oder nicht und einfach zu wissen, Wir wissen, welche Art von Produktion landwirtschaftlicher Natur zum Beispiel am meisten beeinflusst war. Was auch wieder dazu führen kann, dass gewisse Produkte eingeführt werden müssen oder verstärkt eingeführt werden müssen, weil einfach die Produktion in gewissen Ländern oder Gebieten durch heftige Regenfälle, Überflutungen zum Teil auch zerstört wurde. Das ist vielleicht nicht so oft der Fall in Europa, Gott sei Dank, aber in einigen Bereichen in Asien zum Beispiel, Bangladesch, auch Thailand letztes Jahr, hat es enorm starke Überflutungen gegeben, wo ein Großteil der Reisernte einfach vernichtet wurde. Und die Information, die man zum Teil aus Satellitendaten verknüpft, wie gesagt, mit anderen Informationen bekommt, ist einfach essenziell, um abschätzen zu können, dass die heurige Reisernte in Thailand um 60 Prozent oder was auch immer verringert ist. Und dadurch kann sich die Regierung darauf einstellen, neue Reisernten von anderen Ländern, Indonesien, Korea oder wo auch immer, kaufen und einfach sicherstellen, dass sie die richtige Information hat, um die Bevölkerung ganz einfach zu ernähren.
Beziehungsweise gerade das Beispiel in Thailand kann man noch ein bisschen erweitern. Extrem betroffen war ja auch die Industrie, die Ansässige, also gerade so die Festplattenindustrie, das war sehr sichtbar, dass sie da also streckenweise monatelang Betriebe schließen mussten bzw. auch durch ausfallende Zulieferer einfach nicht produzieren konnten, selbst wenn sie jetzt nicht unmittelbar selbst von den Wassermassen betroffen waren. Also das ist ja ohnehin klar, dass fast nichts mehr lokal beschränkt bleibt. Also die wirtschaftliche Verflechtung, nicht nur in Europa, sondern eben auch auf globaler Ebene, produziert ja am laufenden Meter neue Abhängigkeiten, die ja auch streckenweise kaum noch zu überblicken sind, aber auch an der Stelle soll sozusagen GMES helfen. Wie weit ist jetzt dieser Anteil, also Global Monitoring? Ich denke, das ist klar geworden. Es geht also um eine permanente Belieferung von Informationen, eine permanente Beobachtung, auch zum wissenschaftlichen Nutzen. Was verbirgt sich alles hinter dem Bereich Sicherheit? Bezieht sich das jetzt im Wesentlichen nur auf den Katastrophenschutz?
Sicherheit, in der Definition von GMES, also dieses Programmes, wird relativ klar beschrieben als jene Art von Sicherheit, die im zivilen Bereich zu finden ist, aber nicht den militärischen Bereich abdeckt. Typischerweise beinhaltet dies Anwendungen im Katastrophenschutz. Die Anwendungen oder die Informationen, die dort gebraucht werden, sind typischerweise Informationen oder Daten, die sehr hochauflösend sein sollen, aber auch sehr schnell verfügbar sein müssen. Wenn eine Katastrophe irgendwo passiert, welcher Art auch immer, ob das über Flutungen, Feuer oder was auch immer ist, dann muss die Information sehr schnell bereigestellt werden, um eben Hilfe anbieten zu können. Also Katastrophenschutz ist ein ganz typisches Beispiel. Auch humanitäre Hilfe wird als Sicherheit definiert im Sinne von GMES. Humanitäre Hilfe ist typischerweise eine Anwendung, wenn man in gewissen Krisengebieten, irgendwo in Afrika zum Beispiel, einfach wissen muss, wie sieht die Bevölkerungswanderung aus aufgrund von Konflikten?
Also Flüchtlingsströme?
Flüchtlingsströme, weiterhin Zugang von Flüchtlingslagern zum Beispiel zu Wasserquellen, zu Straßen, zu landwirtschaftlichen Gebieten. Also einfach um diese Dynamik zu sehen und auch zu überwachen, was passiert in diesen Krisengebieten. Auch mit dem Zweck oder eigentlich mit dem Zweck, wie kann man besser helfen und wie kann man eingreifen, um erstens die Krise zu verringern, aber auch den humanitären Zustand zu erleichtern. Es gibt ja sehr oft relativ krasse humanitäre Zustände, die ganz einfach gelindert werden muss. Und hier helfen diese Daten auch, um einfach die grundlegende Information bereitzustellen, um zu wissen, was findet sich in der Landschaft, unter welchen Bedingungen sind diese Flüchtlinge oder die Konflikte, Parteien tätig und was kann man tun, um das zu lindern. Ein weiteres Beispiel, was auch in den Sicherheitsbereich fällt, ist zum Beispiel etwas, was neuerlich sehr oft in den Nachrichten aufgekommen ist, und zwar Piraterie. Es werden Daten von unseren Satelliten mitverwendet, um Schiffe zu lokalisieren und auch deren Bewegungen zu überwachen, nachdem sie von Piraten gekapert wurden. Und einfach wiederum um Hilfe anzubieten, um diese Schiffe mit deren Besatzung und deren Güter zu befreien. Und hier werden natürlich Satellitendaten verbunden mit lokaler Information, mit Überfliegungen, mit anderen Informationen, die zur Verfügung stehen. Das wäre ein typischer Beispiel im Sicherheitsbereich von GMES. Ich muss allerdings hinzufügen, dass GMES ein ziviles System ist für zivile Nutzung, allerdings gewisse Anwendungen auch im Sicherheitsbereich stattfinden, die allerdings nicht in den klassischen militärischen Bereich fallen.
Das ganze Monitoring-Programm, so wie du es beschreibst, das klingt für mich so, als ob man eigentlich so viele Satelliten in der Luft haben müsste, dass man eigentlich zu jedem Zeitpunkt überall innerhalb von zehn Minuten hingucken kann. Das wird sicherlich jetzt nicht die technische Anforderung sein. Bei Envisat ist es so, dass man so im üblichen Fall einen Ort nach drei Tagen ein zweites Mal sieht. Was sind da so die Anforderungen für diese Aktualität der Daten? Weil wenn es schon Global Monitoring heißt, klingt es ja nach deutlich geringeren Zeitspannen.
Das ist richtig. Idealerweise wäre das wirklich so, wie du gerade gesagt hast, dass das Monitoring oder die Überwachung kontinuierlich ist. Das ist natürlich eine Geldfrage, eine Frage des Aufwandes, den man betreiben kann. Mit heutigen Satelliten und GMES ist es natürlich ein Schritt in die Richtung eines vollen operationellen Systems. Mit heutigen Systemen, wie wir sie im Rahmen von GMES planen, erhalten wir zum Beispiel Aufnahmen in dem Bereich, in dem Sie gerade von Envisat gesprochen haben, jeden Tag, also täglich einmal pro Tag, zum Teil auch öfter, je nachdem, auf welchem Gebiet der Erde man sich befindet. Das reicht für die meisten Anwendungen aus, um die Information abzuleiten, die man braucht für die Gebiete, die vorher erwähnt wurden. Man muss sich allerdings dessen klar sein, wenn man eine kontinuierlichere Anwendung haben will, das heißt Aufnahmen alle drei Stunden, alle zwei Stunden, dass man dabei ein System aufbauen müsste, das natürlich aus sehr vielen, sehr vielen Satelliten besteht. Das ist eine reine finanzielle Frage. Technisch ist das leicht durchführbar. Sowohl vom Bodensegment als auch vom Satellitensegment. Allerdings kostet natürlich jeder Satellit und jede Starter eine gewisse Geldsumme, die man einfach multiplizieren muss mit der Anzahl der Satelliten, die man dafür braucht. Unser System ist ein relativ komplexes System, bestehend aus vielen einzelnen Satellitenfamilien. Wir haben fünf Serien von Satelliten, Sentinel-1, 2, 3, 4, 5, einfach durchnummeriert. Von den ersten drei Satellitenfamilien, Sentinel-1, 2 und 3, gibt es jeweils Bärchen, also zwei Satelliten, die gleichzeitig im All sind. Diese Bärchen führen schon zu einer wesentlich besseren Auflösung, zeitlichen Auflösung als heutige Systeme, als zum Beispiel Envisat bis vor Kurzem, als zum Beispiel Landsat, der amerikanische Satellit, der eigentlich für die Überwachung der Landoberflächen gemacht wurde, oder auch Spot, der französische Satellit, der auch seit einigen Jahren im Einsatz ist. Das heißt, wir reduzieren, ich nehme nur ein Beispiel, um das klar zu machen, Landsat, also der amerikanische Satellit, gemacht für die Landüberwachung, deckt die gesamte Erdoberfläche alle 16 Tage ab. Das heißt, es braucht 16 Tage, bis die gesamte Oberfläche einmal gesehen wird von Satellitensensoren. Mit Sentinel-2, das ein vergleichbarer Sensor ist, mit etwas besseren Charakteristikern, dauert es fünf Tage, um die Erde abzudecken. Das heißt, von 16 Tagen kommt man auf fünf Tage, was natürlich eine wesentliche Verbesserung ist. Allerdings ist das noch fünf Tage, um den gesamten Globus abzudecken. Das heißt, der gesamte Globus heißt natürlich, dass es einige Gebiete auf der Erdoberfläche gibt, im mittleren Breiten zum Beispiel, die häufiger abgedeckt werden, weil wir natürlich näher an den Polen sind und durch die Umlaufcharakteristik der Satelliten, je näher man am Pol ist, umso häufiger wird ein Gebiet überwacht.
Knöpflich ist immer der Äquatorbereich, weil da einfach am breitesten ist.
Der Äquator ist am breitesten, und deshalb sind die Lücken am größten. Das heißt, mit dem System haben wir schon eine wesentliche Verbesserung erreicht. Will man den nächsten Schritt gehen, also noch kürzere Abdeckungsraten haben oder noch häufiger Überfliegungsraten bekommen, dann muss man schon ein anderes System konzipieren, das dann eigentlich in Richtung Sicherheitssystem geht, wie es eigentlich vom Militär aufgebaut wird, wo man natürlich Anforderungen hat, wo man alle zwei Stunden, alle drei Stunden eine Überwachung über einem Gebiet benötigt. Aber das sind dann wirklich militärische Satelliten. Das ist nicht das, was GMES macht. GMES ist nach, wie ich vorhin bereits gesagt habe, GMES ist ein ziviles System für zivile Anwendungen mit Schwerpunkt Umwelt und in den Umweltfragen oder die Umweltparameter, die wir beobachten, die ändern sich nicht so schnell. Also das sind im Großteil Bewuchs von Landwirtschaftsgebieten, von Waldgebieten und Ähnlichem. Und hier sind die Änderungen natürlich im Rahmen von Wochen, Monaten. Das heißt, die Abdeckungen alle paar Tage sind hier sehr, sehr gut.
Beispiel für eine schnellere Änderung wären natürlich Waldbrände. Auch das ist ja etwas, was bei Envisat mitbeobachtet wurde. Aber das fällt dann halt zwangsläufig dabei ab. Ja, vielleicht sollten wir mal kurz auf die technische Planung eingehen. Also wie das Ganze angedacht ist. Envisat war ja ein großer Klotz mit sehr vielen Instrumenten, zehn verschiedene Module, die eben alle möglichen Aspekte beobachtet haben. Einer der größten, wenn nicht der größte Satellit überhaupt, der so die Erde bisher umrundet hat. Bei GMES geht man aber jetzt einen ganz anderen Weg. Warum macht man das? Also wie macht man es genau und warum macht man das so?
Okay, wie man es genau macht, das heißt in GMES hat man einzelne Satelliten, die man heruntergebrochen hat in kleinere Einheiten.
Das heißt, jedes einzelne Modul vom Envisat kriegt jetzt seinen eigenen Satelliten?
Nicht jedes einzelne, aber es gibt bestimmte Gruppen. Das ist richtig. Zum Beispiel, ganz vereinfacht ausgedrückt, die Fortführung von Envisat, der Instrumentierung auf Envisat mit den zehn Instrumenten, wird fortgeführt durch Sentinel-1, Sentinel-3, Sentinel-5. Das sind jeweils drei Arten, also drei Familien von Sentinel-Satelliten, so nennen sich diese neuen Satelliten, die, nennen wir Sentinel-1 als Beispiel, Sentinel-1 hat ein Radarinstrument, das im C-Band misst, das entspricht in etwa dem Radar auf Envisat, dem ASAR, mit ähnlichen Charakteristiken, allerdings einigen Verbesserungen, unter anderem die Auflösung, also die Bodenauflösung. Und dieses Sentinel-1 führt im Prinzip die Messungen fort, die das ASAR auf Envisat gemacht hat. Allerdings, dadurch, dass wir zwei Satelliten an Bord haben, dadurch, dass wir einen viel breiteren Streifen haben, von fast 300 Kilometern im Vergleich zu 100 Kilometern auf Envisat, führt das dazu, dass die Überdeckung sehr viel häufiger ist.
Also 300 Kilometer am Äquator.
300 Kilometer pro Aufnahmestreifen, der überall, global der gleiche ist. Und diese Streifen überlappen sich natürlich häufiger am Pol als am Äquator. Das heißt, diese breitere Streifen, das ist eine Verdreifachung des Aufnahmestreifens, plus eine weitere Verbesserung des Sentinel-1 im Vergleich zum ESA, ist, dass die Aufnahmezeit während eines Umlaufes, eines Orbits, in etwa 25 Minuten beträgt. Das heißt, 25 Minuten ist ein Viertel eines gesamten Orbits. Ein Orbit dauert etwa 100 Minuten. Das heißt, dass wir während eines Umlaufes des Satelliten um die Erde ein Viertel der Zeit verwenden können, um Bilder aufzunehmen. Das ist mehr als bei Envisat. Envisat hatte eine geringere Aufnahmezeit von etwa 15 Minuten. Und das ist wesentlich mehr als andere Satelliten, wie zum Beispiel Cosmos Kaimeth, der italienische Satellit, der auch ein Radarsatellit ist, aber im X-Band-Bereich arbeitet.
Wurde euch jetzt diese Zeit eingeschränkt durch die Energieversorgung?
Die Zeit ist eingeschränkt durch die Energieversorgung. Die Radarinstrumente brauchen sehr viel Energie. Das sind Radarimpulse, die vom Satelliten auf die Erdoberfläche geschickt werden. Und diese Energie muss über die Solar-Pandels, also über diese Sonnenkollektoren gesammelt werden, in Batterien gespeichert werden und dann für die Instrumente bereit sein, um diese Impulse runterzuschicken und wieder zu empfangen. Das heißt, es gibt hier eine limitierte Aufnahmezeit pro Orbit. Das gibt es nicht bei anderen, bei optischen Satelliten zum Beispiel, beim Sentinel-2, der in etwa eine Fortführung von Landsat on Spot ist. Hier kann man praktisch Tag und Nacht ohne Interbrechung aufnehmen, weil das sind passive Systeme, die nehmen nur, die empfangen die Lichtleistung, also die Information, das ist praktisch wie eine Aufnahme mit digitalen Kameras, allerdings mit sehr vielen Kanälen, die diese Bilder aufnehmen und passiv arbeiten und dadurch ständig eingeschaltet sein können. Und dadurch natürlich mehr Information und mehr Aufnahmegebiete bekommen können, als mit Radar-Instrumenten, die naturgemäß limitiert sind aufgrund der Instrumentierung.
Also Sentinel, das muss man kurz die Begriffe klären. Also GMES ist das Projekt als solches. Sentinel sind jetzt die konkreten Satelliten, die gestartet werden im Rahmen von GMES. Davon gibt es fünf unterschiedliche Typen und manche davon gibt es mehrfach. Zum Beispiel die Nummer eins, da fliegen dann gleichzeitig zwei. Die werden auch gleichzeitig gestartet.
Das ist der Plan. Es gibt diese fünf Familien. Davon haben Sentinel-1, 2 und 3 jeweils ein Pärchen, also zwei Stück im orbit zur gleichen Zeit. Allerdings werden die nicht gleichzeitig gestartet. Das sind volle Satelliten. Sentinel-1 hat eine Masse von etwa 2,4 Tonnen. Das heißt, die beiden werden hintereinander gestartet. Der erste, Sentinel-1 ahnen sich, der erste Satellite soll im Oktober 2013 gestartet werden. Und Sentinel-1B ist noch in Konstruktion, wird etwa 18 Monate später gestartet. Und dann mit dem Start des zweiten Satelliten ist das System voll operationell bezüglich der Aufnahmen im Radarbereich. Sentinel-2 ganz ähnlich. Sentinel-2A soll gestartet werden Anfang 2014. In etwa 18 Monate später Sentinel-2B. Und Sentinel-3, genau das gleiche Schema, Sentinel-3A, Anfang 2014 wird der erste Satellit gestartet, Sentinel-3B, in etwa 18 Monate später.
Wofür ist denn jetzt, also der erste ist Radar. Er setzt das Envisat-ASA, also dieses synthetische Aperture Radar-System von Envisat. Warum hat man sich da jetzt gerade für zwei entschieden? Also geht es da jetzt wirklich um die erhöhte Geschwindigkeit quasi?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Der Hauptgrund, warum wir zwei Satelliten gleichzeitig mal haben, dieser Typ, ist wirklich einer, der kommt aus einer Nutzeranalyse. Also wir haben die einzelnen Dienstleistungsnutzer abgefragt. Ich habe gesagt, wie oft braucht ihr die Daten, welche Art von Daten, welchem Zeitraum. Und das ist das Ergebnis dieser Abfrage. Und zwei sind eben, es werden eben zwei gestartet oder zwei betrieben gleichzeitig, um eben von zehn Tagen Abdeckung der gesamten Erdoberfläche auf fünf Tage herunterzukommen und dadurch einfach die Überflugsfrequenz zu halbieren und einfach mehr Information anzubieten.
Und ist das beliebig skalierbar? Also angenommen die Politik oder sonst jemand, der genug zu sagen hat, meint so, wir brauchen jetzt mal mehr und wir zahlen auch mehr, dann könnte man auch im dritten, vierten und fünften starten.
Wenn man vier zahlen könnte, dann wäre es statt fünf Tagen, wären es dann dividiert durch vier, so 1,25 Tage zum Beispiel.
Also das skaliert sozusagen linear, das hätte einfach mehr.
Das ist in etwa linear skalierbar. Es gibt zwar noch ein paar Orbit-Funktionen, die man berücksichtigen muss, aber im Prinzip ist das linear skalierbar.
Okay, also der erste kümmert sich um Radar, der zweite ist ein optisches System, ersetzt Landsat und Sport.
Richtig, ersetzt Landsat und Sport. Landsat und Sport, der dritte ersetzt zwei Instrumente auf Envisat, und zwar das ETSA und das Meeresinstrument. Das sind auch optische und Infrarotsensoren, die vor allem für großflächige Aufnahmen der Land- und Ozeanoberflächen verwendet werden. Ozeanoberflächendemperaturen zum Beispiel mit sehr hoher Genauigkeit, auch Landinformation zur globalen Überwachung der Abholzung der landwirtschaftlichen Bewuchses, über dem Ozean wiederum für Informationen, die mit Eisbedeckung zusammenhängen, also welche Gebiete mit Eis bedeckt sind. Dann gibt es auch einen weiteren Sensor am Sentinel-3, einen Altimeter, das ist ein Höhenmesser eigentlich, also ein Instrument, das die Entfernung zwischen Satellit- und Meeresoberfläche oder Landoberfläche misst. Und mit diesem Instrument kann man typischerweise die Wellenbewegungen des Ozeans bestimmen, und zwar mit sehr, sehr hoher Genauigkeit von zwei Zentimetern, zwei bis drei Zentimetern, was natürlich enorm wichtig ist für die Schifffahrt, für die Metrologie, für alle Anwendungen, die einfach mit Meeresbewegungen zu tun haben, unter anderem auch Windfarmen. Wenn man Windturbinen zum Beispiel aufbauen will, ist es enorm wichtig, abzuschätzen, welche Wellenbewegungen zu erwarten sind, nicht nur um den Aufbau durchzuführen, aber auch um die Reparaturen durchführen zu können. Zum Beispiel, ich war neulich in einer Konferenz in Bremerhaven und es ist uns berichtet worden von Windfarmbetreibern vor der deutschen Küste, dass ein Schiff, um Reparaturen an solchen Windmassen durchzuführen, in etwa sieben Stunden braucht, um vom Land zur Windfarm zu gelangen. Es ist enorm wichtig zu wissen, was ist der Wellengang, kann man die Reparaturen überhaupt durchführen oder nicht, abhängig vom Wellengang und von Windgeschwindigkeit. Durch gute Vorhersagen dieser Information kann man enorm viel Geld sparen, weil man das Schiff entweder hinausschicken kann und optimiert einsetzen kann oder im Extremfall eben nicht verwenden kann, wenn die Bedingungen nicht gut genug sind. Das sind zum Beispiel typische Anwendungen, wo solche Informationen im täglichen wirtschaftlichen Bereich eingesetzt werden.
Ich denke jetzt gerade die vor kurzem verunglückte Fähre, die da immer noch im Wasser vor Italien liegt, die ja auch geborgen werden muss und wahrscheinlich auf ähnliche Bedingungen setzen muss.
Ganz richtig.
Und die anderen beiden Sentinels, vier und fünf?
Die anderen beiden Sentinels, vier und fünf, ist eine Familie von atmosphärischen Chemieinstrumenten. Es werden einige atmosphärische Parameter damit gemessen, zum Beispiel Methan, NOx, SO2, zum Teil auch CO2 und ein paar davon abgeleitete Substanzen. Hauptzweck dieser beiden Sateliten ist wirklich die Bestimmung der Luftqualität. Und zwar Sentinel-4 fliegt in einem geostationären Orbit, ist ein Instrument auf dem MTG-Satelliten, Meteor Satellite Generation Satelliten, und misst vom geostationären Orbit mit relativ großer Zeitauflösung die atmosphärischen Parameter. Das heißt, der beobachtet auch nur Europa? Der beobachtet nur Europa, richtig, also Europa und Umgebung, Afrika und Europa von einem Punkt aus, wie es ein Meteor Satellite zum Beispiel auch macht, während Sentinel-5 ein polarumlaufender Satellit ist, die höhere räumliche Auflösung bietet, aber geringere zeitliche Auflösung. Und die Kombination aus hoher zeitlicher Auflösung von Sentinel-4 aus dem geostationären Orbit mit der hohen zeitlichen Auflösung, mit der hohen räumlichen Auflösung von Sentinel-5 aus dem niedrigen Orbit gibt ein dreidimensionales Bild über die Luftqualität und die Ernausbreitung.
Das heißt, 4 und 5 sind mit ähnlichen Instrumenten ausgestattet?
Sind ähnliche Instrumente, die in Kombination zu verwenden sind.
Ah, verstehe. Das eine höhere Genauigkeit, das andere Permanenz. Das heißt, 4 und 5 gehören zusammen. Sprich, eigentlich könnte man sagen, es gibt vier Arten von Sentinels und es gibt immer zwei davon, nur dass in diesem einen Fall eben der Umlaufweg einfach ein ganz anderer ist.
Das kann man so sagen.
Im anderen Fall einfach nur eine weitere Redundanz bzw. Erhöhung der Zeitfrequenz ist. Warum packt man nicht 1, 2 und 3 alles auf einen? Wenn die sowieso alle irgendwie ähnlich laufen, warum macht man das dann nicht wie bei Envisat, dass man dann einfach so ein großes Paket macht und man wirft die hoch und wäre es dann zu schwer? Oder das andere Erkenntnis?
Okay, die Zeiten ändern sich und auch im Design von Satelliten ändert sich die Zeit. Envisat wurde entwickelt, entworfen, als die internationale Raumstation auch aufgebaut wurde. Und damals hat man geglaubt, man muss möglichst große Plattformen erzeugen, entwickeln, die mit vielen Instrumenten ausgestattet möglichst viel messen. Dieser Trend hat sich komplett geändert. Wir haben heute relativ kleinere, fokussiertere Einheiten, zum Beispiel die Sentinels, was natürlich dazu führt, dass man die Instrumente optimieren kann und auf die Anwendung gezielter dimensionieren kann. Es gibt auch andere Gründe.
Warum hat das jetzt so unmittelbar auf das Instrument? Hat das erstmal keine Auswirkung im Instrument? Ist ja egal, ob es zusammen mit anderen noch auf irgendwas montiert wird?
Nicht unbedingt. Nehmen wir das Beispiel Envisat. Envisat hat optische Instrumente und ein Radarinstrument, also das ASA, an Bord gehabt. Das ASA ist zum Beispiel um etwa 10.30 Uhr morgens lokaler Ortszeit jeweils über die einzelnen Punkte der Erde geflogen. Natürlich hat sich der Orbit mit der Erddrehung verschoben. 10.30 Uhr ist ein optimaler Zeitpunkt für die optischen Instrumente, weil hier die Beleuchtung aufgrund der Sonneneinstrahlung optimal ist, es durch keine direkten Reflexionen kommt und die Beleuchtung konstant ist. Das heißt, wenn man täglich über verschiedene Punkte der Erde um 10.30 Uhr in etwa lokale Zeit fliegt, kann man die Messungen zwischen Deutschland und Thailand und China vergleichen. Und deshalb ähnliche Parameter abschätzen. 10.30 Uhr ist aber nicht die optimale Zeit für ein Radarinstrument, weil Radarinstrumente am besten zur Morgendämmerung und zur Abenddämmerung fliegen. Und das hat rein energetische Gründe, weil die Orbits, die damit verbunden sind, um 6.30 Uhr, etwa 6 Uhr in der Früh und 6 Uhr am Abend über die Punkte zu fliegen, optimal die Verfügbarkeit des Sonnenlichtes ausnützt. Und dadurch, wie vorher bereits erwähnt, dass Sonnenlicht notwendig ist, um die Batterien aufzuladen und die Radarimpulse auszusenden, das spricht, das Radar zu betreiben, ist aufgrund von energierelevanten Überlegungen der beste Zeitpunkt oder der beste Orbit, ein Dawn-Dusk-Orbit, wie man das im Englischen nennt, also ein Morgen- und Abenddämmerungs-Orbit. Und das ist eben ganz anders als zum Beispiel 10.30 Uhr Orbit auf Envisat. Das heißt, wenn man mehr Instrumente auf eine große Plattform packt, geht man natürlich Kompromisse ein. Und ein solcher Kompromiss war eben, dass eben die Überflugszeit für ein Radarinstrument nicht ideal war auf Envisat. Wenn man natürlich das Instrument wegnimmt, kann man das optimieren. Andere Gründe, und das ist auch, glaube ich, ein taktischer Grund, ist natürlich, wenn man alle Instrumente auf einen großen Satelliten hinaufklemmt und dort festmacht, sollte der Start des Satelliten schiefgehen, dann hat man sehr viel Geld und sehr viele Instrumente verloren, ist alles weg. Sollte der Satellit ausfallen frühzeitig, dann ist natürlich alles weg. Und wenn man kleinere, fokussierte Satelliten baut, ist natürlich das Risiko auch gestreut.
Und am Ende ist sogar auch noch der Aspekt Weltraumschrott vielleicht ein Aspekt dabei?
Der Aspekt Weltraumschrott ist auch ein wichtiger Aspekt. Ich muss sagen, hier hat sich auch einiges getan im Laufe der Zeit. Zu Zeiten von Envisat war es noch nicht verpflichtend oder bindend, zumindest nach internationalen Richtlinien, dass die Satelliten entorbited werden können, wie man das so schön ausdrückt. Also sprich, dass noch genug Treibstoff an Bord ist, um den Satelliten in eine niedrigere Umlaufbahn zu bringen und dadurch gestürzt zum Absturz bringen kann, was natürlich besser ist, als wenn man ihn nur laufen lässt, bis er von selber in die Atmosphäre eintritt.
Weil das kann lange dauern?
Weil das kann sehr lange dauern. Bei Envisat kann das 150 Jahre oder ähnliches dauern. Die neuen Satelliten, also das ist nicht nur die Sentinel, sondern alle neueren Satelliten, bauen die Möglichkeit ein, dass sie noch genügend Treibstoff an Bord behalten, auch wenn die Instrumentierung bereits nicht mehr funktioniert. Damit sie noch aus dem aktuellen, aktiven Orbit abgebaut werden können in tiefe Umlaufbahnen und dann gezielt in die Erdatmosphäre eindringen können. Und dadurch natürlich der Weltraumschrott verringert wird.
Und ein kleinerer Satellit braucht dann auch nicht so viel Energie?
Ein kleinerer Satellit braucht weniger Energie, um die Orbit zu werden.
Das heißt, das sind eigentlich so ganz praktisch handfeste Gründe, die sich jetzt nicht nur in diesem GMES-Programm niederschlagen, sondern die eigentlich ein genereller Trend sind in der Raumfahrt, dass man eher sagt, lieber mehr dedizierte Operationen, die unabhängig voneinander sind, um das Risiko zu minimieren und aber auch Startkosten dürften ja auch deutlich niedriger ausfallen, als wenn man da so einen Drum nach oben jagt. Inwiefern ist denn jetzt dieses Projekt schon auf dem Weg und beschlossen? Also es ist ja jetzt so eine Lücke entstanden, dadurch, dass Envisat nicht mehr funktioniert, auch wenn er schon deutlich länger lief, als er eigentlich sollte, oder man hätte eigentlich hoffen können, aber dann waren es ja dann zehn statt fünf Jahre. Trotz alledem fehlt das Ding jetzt irgendwie. Also da wird sicherlich die ein oder andere Träne auch verdrückt worden sein in den letzten Monaten, weil einfach der Datenstrom abgerissen ist. Wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe, startet der erste Satellit 2013, aber erst im Laufe von 14, 15 wird man dann so quasi wieder an demselben Punkt angekommen sein, wo man jetzt mit Envisat war.
Ja, das ist richtig. Envisat ist natürlich unser Workhorse gewesen, also unser Arbeitspferd im Sinne von Beobachtungen, die benötigt wurden für die einzelnen Bereiche. Hat fantastische Arbeit geleistet, hat wie gesagt zehn Jahre statt fünf Jahre gelebt und Daten geliefert. Aber was etwas unerwartet war und eigentlich früher noch als erwartet war, dass Envisat bereits vor eineinhalb Monaten nicht mehr aktiv erreicht werden konnte. Das ist richtig, wir haben jetzt eine Datenlücke zwischen Envisat und Sentinel-1. Die Datenlücke ist in etwa ein Jahr und eineinhalb Jahre. Und das ist natürlich ein Problem für einige Dienstleistungen, für einige Anwendungen. Ein Beispiel ist einige Ozeanbeobachtungen, die enorm darunter gelitten haben. Wie vorhin erwähnt, sind Oberflächendemperaturen, Windbewegungen, Wellenbewegungen des Meeres von diesen Satelliten gemessen worden. Also von Envisat gemessen worden. Und wir warten jetzt auf Sentinel-1, um diese ähnlichen Parameter sogar noch besser zu bekommen. Was wir jetzt machen, ist, wir sind in der glücklichen Lage für das C-Band-Radar-Instrumente, dass es ein ähnliches Instrument in Kanada gibt, also einen ähnlichen Satelliten in Kanada, der nennt sich Radarsat, der auch im C-Band Messungen durchführt. Wir haben schon zur Lebenszeit von Envisat mit der kanadischen Weltraumagentur ein Abkommen abgeschlossen, das besagt, sollte einer der beiden Satelliten, entweder der europäische oder der kanadische Satellit, frühzeitig ausfallen, dann verpflichtet sich die andere Agentur, für einen Zeitraum von drei Monaten Daten zur Verfügung zu stellen, um des anderen Bedarfs abzudecken. Die Idee dabei ist, dass ein Satellit manchmal technische Probleme hat, die vielleicht einen Monat, zwei Monate benötigen, um gefunden und behoben zu werden. Und das wäre in dieser Zeit natürlich der Partner, der internationale Partner, in dem Fall Kanada, diesen Datenbedarf abdeckt oder abdecken kann. Das ist jetzt eingetroffen, wir haben Envisat verloren. Kanada liefert Daten für die nächsten drei Monate gratis. Nach den drei Monaten müssen die Daten gekauft werden zu den gängigen Gebühren, um die diese Daten zur Verfügung stehen. Die kanadischen Daten sind nicht billig. Die sind relativ teuer, das heißt, Europa muss relativ viel Geld jetzt investieren, um Daten aus dem Ausland zu kaufen. Genau diese Radarsat-Daten, das ist ein Problem. Das zweite Problem ist, dass Envisat natürlich ein Arbeitstier war, was diese Aufnahmen betrifft, sehr viele Daten geliefert hat. Wir haben für GMES zum Beispiel Daten im Gegenwert von etwa 30 Millionen geliefert, die jetzt weg sind. Das heißt, dass der kanadische Satellit natürlich ausgerichtet ist auf die Bedürfnisse Kanadas, um die kanadischen Küstengebiete, die kanadischen Eisgebiete und ähnliches zu überwachen. Und die europäischen Bedürfnisse natürlich dann abgedeckt werden, wenn noch freie Ressourcen zur Verfügung sind. Das heißt, wir sind natürlich der zweite rangige Kunde, der die Daten bekommt, die halt noch aufgenommen werden können. Sprich, sehr viele dieser Erwartungen, die wir eigentlich haben, können nicht befriedigt werden. Das heißt, wir haben zwar einen Dienst, der bereitgestellt wird durch die kanadischen Daten, aber das ist wirklich ein Notdienst, der halt eine gewisse Zeit helfen kann, diese Situation zu überbrücken, aber nicht langfristig gewährleisten kann, was gebraucht wird. Es ist ganz ähnlich mit den anderen Instrumenten, aber für einige Instrumente zum Beispiel gibt es keinen Ersatz und diese Dienste können einfach nicht weitergeführt werden.
Das heißt, es gibt so eine kleine Notlösung, aber eigentlich warten wir schon...
Wir waren schon ganz gespannt auf den Start des ersten Satelliten.
Und der ist aber jetzt schon on track, also da ist sozusagen...
Der ist on track. Wir sind gerade derzeit dabei, mit unseren Entscheidungsträgern den Starttermin zu fixieren. Es gibt hier... Okay, vom Technischen läuft alles sehr gut. Also der Satellit wird fertig sein für Oktober 2013, um gestartet zu sein.
Von wo startet der dann?
Von KORU in Südamerika.
Mit einer Ariane oder...?
Ne, mit einer Soyuz-Rakete. Es gibt ein kleines Problem. Und das Problem ist, dass GMES finanziert wird durch die europäischen Steuergelder, sowohl im Rahmen der ESA als auch im Rahmen der Europäischen Union. Wir haben bisher das Geld organisiert für die Entwicklung des Systems, aber nicht für den Betrieb. Also nicht für die Zeit nach dem Start. Also der Start ist finanziert. Auch die Verifizierung der Instrumente im Orbit, das etwa drei Monate dauert, ist verifiziert und finanziert, aber nicht der langfristige Betrieb. Das mag etwas eigenartig klingen.
Wie lange soll denn dieser Betrieb eigentlich sein? Also wie lange soll der 1er Sentinel laufen?
Alle Sateliten, alle Sentinels, 1, 2, 3, haben die gleiche nominelle Laufzeit von sieben Jahren mit einer Möglichkeit bis zu zwölf Jahren. Also das heißt, nominelle Laufzeit ist diejenige Laufzeit, für die die Bauteile ausgerichtet sind. Aber es passiert auch immer wieder, wie auch bei Envisat, dass Satelliten länger leben. Das heißt, die Consumables, so nennt sich das im Englischen, sind so ausgerichtet, dass bis maximal zwölf Jahre der Satellit betrieben werden kann und dann noch deorbited werden kann, wenn nötig. Zurück zur komplexen oder zur prekären Situation in Europa mit GMES. Wir haben das Geld, um die Satelliten zu launchen, also zu starten, zu verifizieren, aber nicht zu betreiben. Das ist fast so, wie wenn man das Geld hätte, um ein Auto zu entwickeln, das Auto zu bauen. Es wird dann vor die Tür gestellt, der Schlüssel steckt, der Motor kann nicht laufen, weil kein Benzin im Tank ist und das Geld steht nicht zur Verfügung, um das Auto wirklich zu fahren, wofür es eigentlich gebaut wurde. Und das ist genau die Situation, in der wir heute sind. Das mag sehr eigentümlich und eigenartig klingen, aber genau das ist es. Die Idee dahinter ist, und das ist natürlich die große Politik hier in Europa, dass die Entwicklungskosten zum größten Teil von der ESA als Weltraumagentur, als Forschungs- und Entwicklungsagentur für Weltraumtechnologie finanziert werden. Aber dass der operationelle Betrieb eigentlich von der Europäischen Union finanziert werden soll, die die Politik und den Nutzer repräsentiert. Sprich, die Finanzierung geht schwerpunktmäßig von der ESA über auf die Europäische Kommission in Brüssel. Und wir sind genau an diesem Zeitpunkt. Die Entscheidungen für diese Gelder, für die Operationen werden gerade jetzt getroffen im Rahmen des Europäischen Unionsbudgets 2014 bis 2020. Und hier sollte GMES ein Teil dieses Gesamtbudgets sein, um unter anderem auch die Sentinel-S zu betreiben.
Das heißt, wenn da jetzt nicht in ein bisschen Bewegung in die Debatte kommt, ist das alles so ein bisschen unklar, ob man überhaupt starten kann.
So kann man sagen. Deshalb arbeitet die Politik Tag und Nacht daran, dass diese Bewegung eben zustande kommt. Und das ist einer der, ich würde sagen, in der europäischen Weltraumpolitik eine der brennenden Fragen, die derzeit diskutiert wird, wie kann natürlich sichergestellt werden, dass diese Finanzierung bestmöglich und zeitgerecht zustande kommt.
Jetzt hat sich ja schon bei Envisat gezeigt, und das ist ja hier in gewisser Hinsicht bei GMES schon ein bisschen eingepreist, dass eben so der Nutzen für die Gesellschaft, wir haben ja ein paar Punkte schon auch herausgehoben, gerade was so den Katastrophenschutz betrifft, das ist ja jetzt nicht so ein täglicher Nutzen, aber im Falle dessen ist es auf jeden Fall wünschenswert, natürlich auch solche Quellen anzapfen zu können. Da können wir nochmal so ein bisschen mehr darüber reden, welche konkret absehbaren Nutzbarkeit von GMES existiert und wo unter Umständen sich auch ein Potential abzeichnet, wo es sein könnte, dass sich komplett neue Felder auftun, die man aber jetzt, sagen wir mal, noch nicht so fest eingeplant hat und wo man es noch nicht weiß, oder wo es vielleicht von einem gewissen wissenschaftlichen, technischen Entwicklung noch abhängt.
GMES hat einen sehr vielfältigen und relativ zahlreichen Nutzer, also mit sehr vielen Anwendungsgebieten. Das geht wirklich quer durch den Gemüsegarten, wenn man so sagen kann, also von der Landwirtschaft oder der Forstwirtschaft, Katastrophenschutz, Klimaschutz, Sicherheitsfragen und Ähnliches. Es hat neulich eine Studie gegeben, die durchgeführt wurde von Aufbau und Arbeiten von Preisworterhaus Kupers an Busellen, die versucht haben, den Nutzen von GMES herauszuarbeiten für die Wirtschaft oder für die Gesellschaft als Gesamtes.
Den Nutzen in welcher Form quantifiziert?
Den ökonomischen Nutzen quantifiziert. Also in Geld sozusagen. Wie viel Nutzen bringt ein System dieser Art, wenn man zum Beispiel einen Euro investiert, wie viel Nutzen kommt zurück in die Gesellschaft? Diese Studien sind gerade abgeschlossen worden. Die zeigen, dass ein Euro investiert in GMES einen Nutzen für die Gesellschaft bringt, der in etwa zehn Euro entspricht. Woher kommt der Nutzen? Der Nutzen kommt zum Beispiel durch bessere Information. Ich habe vorhin das Beispiel erwähnt, der Schiffe, die zu einem Windfahren hinausfahren und durch bessere Information wissen, ob sie rausfahren können oder nicht. Der Nutzen kommt auch durch andere Schiffe, die zum Beispiel durch Eisgebiete navigieren müssen und einfach die bessere Route weniger Diesel kostet und dadurch billiger kommt. Aber auch durch geringere Schäden im Katastrophenschutzbereich, in dem man einfach frühzeitig bessere Information hat, um Überflutungen großer Gebiete zu verhindern, um große Ölverseuchungen zum Beispiel besser bekämpfen zu können und Ähnliches.
Aber das sind ja jetzt zwei Beispiele, wo ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass es etwas schwer zu vermitteln ist. Auf der einen Seite so große Schiffe, hat natürlich jetzt nicht jeder so, da denkt man natürlich schnell, naja, da profitieren dann die Räder davon, dass sie irgendwie ihre großen Schiffe da besser getrackt bekommen. Und im anderen Fall Katastrophen, naja, wie ich schon sagte, man ist mal sehr dankbar, wenn es dann im Falle eines Falles da ist, aber wie realistisch man solche Katastrophen für sich selber sieht, solange sie noch nicht passiert sind, weiß man ja auch. Das ist etwas, das ist so, naja, das passiert immer den anderen. Erst wenn es einem selber passiert, dann ist man halt betroffen und dann ist es auf einmal wichtig. Also vielleicht könnten wir auch nochmal so ein bisschen vielleicht so diesen gesamtgesellschaftlichen Nutzen noch ein bisschen über solche einzelnen Beispiele hinaus abstecken.
Lassen Sie mich ein anderes Beispiel nennen. Wir haben zum Beispiel Landwirtschaft. Viele Gebiete Europas leben ja von der Landwirtschaft und sind sehr landwirtschaftsintensiv. Obwohl natürlich die Bevölkerung als solches, also der Bevölkerungsanteil relativ gering ist, aber der landwirtschaftliche Faktor als Wirtschaftsfaktor ist nach wie vor ein wichtiger. Es gibt, das nennt sich im Englischen, Precision Farming, also Präzisionslandwirtschaft, wo zum Beispiel Satellitendaten verwendet werden in Kombination mit Navigationssystemen um die Beackerung der landwirtschaftlichen Flächen besser durchzuführen. Beispiel? Beispiel, Düngung richtig. Über große landwirtschaftliche Gebiete kann man mit dieser Information aus Satellitendaten bestimmen, welche Gebiete trockener, feuchter sind, mehr oder weniger produzieren und die Düngung entsprechend einstellen. Das heißt, es gibt bereits Traktoren, die versehen sind mit einem GPS und Informationen aus dem Satellitenbild und die Düngung entlang des Streifens, den sie abfahren, entsprechend dieser Information einstellen. Das heißt, man kann Geld sparen, indem man einfach weniger Düngemittel aufs Feld streuen muss.
Und dementsprechend auch die Umweltbelastung zurückfahren.
Und dementsprechend die Umweltbelastung reduzieren kann.
Wie fein wäre die Auflösung da?
Also die beste Auflösung der optischen Satelliten heute, die kommerziell erhältlich sind, ist weniger als ein Meter. Also 60 Zentimeter, 70 Zentimeter je nach Hersteller.
Das heißt, man könnte die Düngung auf den Quadratmeter hin optimieren?
Man kann sicher auf das Feld, also auf den Quadratmeter hin, die Düngung optimieren. Man verwendet eigentlich Satelliten mit etwas weniger genauer Auflösung, weil eigentlich diese Präzision nicht so genau notwendig ist. Typischerweise verwendet man Satelliten mit 2 Meter, 3 Meter, 4 Meter Auflösung, das mehr als ausreichend ist für diesen Zweck.
Man braucht natürlich auch eine entsprechende Genauigkeit dann im Traktor. Dann kommt natürlich ein anderes Projekt wieder ins Spiel, nämlich Galileo, was ja dann auch entsprechende Präzision in der Navigation ermöglicht.
Ganz richtig, ja. Es ist eine Kombination, dass es mehr und mehr der Fall sein wird, aus Erdbeobachtungssatelliten mit Navigationssatelliten, sprich GMES mit Galileo und andere Informationen, die natürlich auch zur Verfügung stehen muss, wie zum Beispiel Bodenkarten, Pflanzen, Bewuchsmodelle und Ähnliches, dass natürlich alles integriert wird in ein Informationssystem, das in diesem Fall verwendet wird. Aber es gibt bereits am Markt Traktoren zu verkaufen, mit oder ohne GPS-Modul, mit oder ohne Satellitenmodul, um eben diese Düngung, wie gesagt, auf einem System alle durchführen zu können.
Galileo ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch ähnlich wie GMES, auch politischer aufgehängt als ein übliches Raumfahrtprogramm.
Galileo ist neben GMES das andere europäische Flagship-Projekt im Weltraum. So nennen sich diese Projekte. Galileo hat natürlich eine ganz andere Aufgabenstellung, ist auch ein anderes System, dient in dem Fall der Navigation, also das europäische GPS, wenn man so schön sagen kann, während GMES viel komplexer aufgebaut ist und viel mehr Komponenten und Elemente hat. Ein Punkt, der noch ganz wichtig ist bei GMES, zu erwähnen ist natürlich der Beitrag, nicht nur der Sentinel-Satelliten, die wir gerade besprochen haben, sondern GMES hat auch eine Aktivität, die sich mit dem Kauf oder mit dem Zugang zu allen möglichen Daten befasst, die verfügbar sind für einen gewissen Bedarf. Sprich, es gibt Satelliten in Deutschland, TerraSat an dem X zum Beispiel, die natürlich enorm wichtige Satelliten sind. Die sind nicht für GMES gebaut worden, aber GMES ist einer der wichtigen Nutzer für diese Satelliten. Ähnliches für Italien, Ähnliches für Frankreich, Ähnliches für englische Satelliten, für spanische Satelliten und so weiter. Das heißt, mit GMES verwendet man oder GMES Dienstleistungen verwenden nicht nur die Sentinel-Daten, sondern auch die nationalen Daten, die verfügbar sind und die bereits für, sage ich mal, andere Zwecke gebaut wurden, aber auch für GMES einen sehr großen Nutzen darstellen. Das heißt, hier haben wir ein Bodensegment entwickelt, das es erlaubt, auf diese Daten zuzugreifen, diese Daten in den Planungszyklus einzubauen, weil für den Nutzer es eigentlich egal ist, ob er einen Sentinel-Datensatz oder einen TerraSat-Datensatz bekommt, solange die Information natürlich die Energie ist, die er braucht für seinen Bedarf. Und dadurch ist GMES natürlich auch komplexer als Galileo, weil wir hier wirklich eine Vielzahl von Satelliten haben, die wir zugreifen, die natürlich alle unterschiedlich sind, unterschiedliche Formate haben, unterschiedliche Parameter haben, unterschiedliche Arten und Weisen haben, wie die Daten geliefert werden. Während Galileo relativ geradlinig Navigationsdaten liefert und eine Information, nämlich eine Positionsinformation, bereitstellt.
Wir fallen jetzt hier in eine ganze Reihe von Raumzeitausgaben ein, in dem Kontext, die vielleicht für diejenigen, die da noch nicht reingehört haben, an dieser Stelle auch interessant werden könnten. Raumzeit 37 hat sich zum Beispiel mit Tandem X sehr ausführlich auseinandergesetzt, aber auch Galileo haben wir hier schon etwas detaillierter, vor allem auch technisch sehr viel detaillierter besprochen, in Ausgabe Nummer 8. Ich fühle mich aber gerade noch an etwas anderes erinnert. Es gibt ja bei der ESA auch dieses Technology Transfer Program, was so ein bisschen diese Frage des Verhältnisses von wirtschaftlicher Entwicklung, auch Gründung von neuen Unternehmen auf Basis von Entwicklung und auch den Bedarf von Raumfahrtentwicklung in der Zukunft etabliert hat. Hier sehe ich aber bei GMES auch so einen Faktor, dass durch den Betrieb dieser Satellitensysteme in Zukunft komplett neue Dienstleistungen in der Wirtschaft einerseits erforderlich werden, aber eben vielleicht auch erst entstehen, wo die Idee vielleicht auch erst noch geboren werden muss. Wie ist denn das organisatorisch im GMES-Projekt aufgehängt, diesen, da gibt es ja einen Bedarf für einen Informationsaustausch, diesen Informationsaustausch auch zu betreiben und diese Schnittstelle zur Industrie herzustellen, jenseits von der eigentlichen Raumfahrtenplanung?
Ja, das ist ganz richtig. GMES hat nicht nur zum Ziel, die Standardbedürfnisse zu befriedigen, die wir mit Envisat aufgebaut haben, sondern wirklich neue Felder zu erkunden, wo Geschäft gemacht werden kann, wo Geld gemacht werden kann und wo wirklich die Raumfahrt dazu beiträgt, neue Technologien, neue Segmente zu öffnen. Ich nenne nur ein ganz wichtiger Faktor, den wir dabei beachten müssen, ist die Datenpolitik. Unter welchen Bedingungen bekommen die Leute die Satellitendaten bereitgestellt? Wir hatten ja bisher, klassisch oder traditionellerweise, eine relativ restriktivere Datenpolitik als zum Beispiel Amerika, oder Amerika vor allem, hatte. Auch Envisat-Daten wurden mehr und mehr gelockert und freier zur Verfügung gestellt, aber es war noch immer ein relativ aufwendiger Prozess notwendig, um sich zu registrieren, um in die Daten zu kommen und ähnliches. Mit den Sentinels wollen wir wirklich eine komplett freie und offene Datenpolitik einführen. Das ist ein relativ wichtiger Schritt, eigentlich ein Wandel im Vergleich zu bisherigen Praktiken. Das heißt, die Daten, die die Sentinels erzeugen werden, und das werden sehr, sehr viele Daten sein, werden jedem Nutzer, jedem gratis zur Verfügung gestellt werden. Der kann sie über Internet...
Jedem global, egal ob EU oder nicht EU.
Egal ob EU oder nicht EU. Das heißt, es gibt Internetportale, wo die Daten einfach abgerufen werden können. Mit Mausklick stimmt man den Nutzungsbedingungen zu und dann kann man die Daten runterladen. Und das ist natürlich eine große Änderung im Vergleich zu herkömmlichen bisherigen Methoden, um an die Daten ranzukommen.
Und wie sind die Nutzungsbedingungen?
Die sind simpel. Okay, wir haben sie noch nicht definiert, aber da wird im Prinzip drinstehen, dass die ESA nicht verantwortlich gemacht werden kann für die Nutzung der Daten oder die Konsequenz der Nutzung und die Standardklauseln, die normalerweise drinstehen. Aber ganz wichtig, wir erlauben den Nutzern, dass sie die Daten gratis verwenden können für welche Bedürfnisse auch immer.
Also egal, ob da ein kommerzielles oder ein nicht-komerzielles Interesse dahintersteht.
Ganz richtig. Im Gegenteil, wir sind sogar interessiert, wenn kommerzielle Firmen die Daten verwenden für neue kommerzielle Anwendungen, die sie dabei entwickeln. Und ich glaube, diese Datenpolitik ist ein ganz wichtiger Faktor, um wirklich neue Geschäftsideen zu entwickeln. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass kleine Firmen, die im Geoinformationsbereich arbeiten, sich die Satelliten-Daten anschauen, runterladen. Das kostet ja nichts. Mal überlagern mit derzeitigen Karten oder anderen Informationen und einfach spielen und neue Ideen entwickeln und dadurch neue Dienstleistungen entwickeln können. Und ich vermute, das können auch Zeitungen sein, das können auch Fernsehstationen sein. Die Daten werden einfach mehr Teil des täglichen Informationsgutes der Bevölkerung sein.
Fallen denn bei einem Sentinel-Projekt auch so richtige Erdfotografien ab? Also das, was man heute aus den im Internet verbreiteten Landkartensystemen kennt? Kriegt man richtige Fotos oder sind das jetzt wirklich nur die wissenschaftlichen Bilder?
Nein, das kommt auf den Datensatz darauf an. Also Sentinel-1 ist ein Radarsatz, der etwas komplizierter zu interpretieren ist. Aber Sentinel-2 zum Beispiel, das ist ein optisches System. Und wenn man die richtigen drei Kanäle überlagert, dann schaut das aus wie ein Foto. Wie ein Foto der Erde vom Weltrand.
Das heißt, diese Sentinel-Daten könnten zum Beispiel auch in so freie Systeme wie OpenStreetMap einfließen?
Absolut, absolut. Und wir sind gerade dabei, solche Ideen zu entwickeln, also auch mit jungen Leuten, jungen kleineren und mittelgroßen Betrieben. Ein Beispiel ist ein GMES-Masters, der in Deutschland durchgeführt wird, wo es darum geht, dass wir einfach neue Ideen prämieren, also mit Preisen versehen, die die potenzielle Nutzung dieser Daten irgendwie sich erdenken und neue Ideen entwickeln und so weiter. Dieser Preis findet einmal im Jahr statt, wird in München durchgeführt. Die Bewerber kommen aus ganz Europa und typischerweise kommen junge Firmen, auch Universitätsabgänger, Studenten, die einfach Vorschläge einreichen. Das ist ein relativ formloses Ansuchen. Und die besten Ideen werden bekommen einen Preis, aber auch um neue Ideen zu stimulieren und zu entwickeln. Ein anderes Beispiel, nächste Woche hier in Frascati findet etwas ganz Interessantes statt, ein sogenanntes AppCamp für Applications, wie sie auf iPhones oder Android Mobiltelefonen zu verwenden sind. Hier laden wir 20 junge Programmierer im Informationstechnologiebereich ein für eine Woche. Die bekommen Flüge, Logis, Essen finanziert und werden aufgefordert für eine Woche in kleineren Gruppen Ideen zu entwickeln, wie man Satellitendaten einfach verwenden kann im täglichen Gebrauch. Unsere Vorgaben halten sich in Grenzen. Das heißt, die Leute können spielen, die können programmieren, können entwickeln, was Spaß macht und was Sinn macht und was vielleicht zu neuen Entwicklungen führen kann. Und das ist eine Art und Weise, einfach um auch Ideen zu sammeln von unserer Seite durch diese junge Gruppe von höchst kreativen, höchst begabten Informationstechnologieleutner, die einfach entwickeln, einfach arbeiten und am Ende des Tages kommt dann wahrscheinlich sehr viel Interessantes dabei raus.
Bevor jetzt die Leute gleich anfangen, danach zu suchen, zum Zeitpunkt der Ausstrahlung dieser Sendung ist dieses Abcamp schon gelaufen. Aber die Anmeldungsfrist von dem GMES Masters ist, wenn ich das richtig sehe, der 16. September 2012. Da gibt es noch eine gute Gelegenheit, da vielleicht teilzunehmen. Also ich finde den Aspekt besonders interessant, weil das hat mich tatsächlich auch bei den Gesprächen, insbesondere über Erdbeobachtungen, hier auch in der Raumzeitserie, immer wieder so ein bisschen geärgert, dass eben viele Daten gesammelt werden. Aber eben der Weg von diesen Daten zu jemanden, der da interessante Schlussfolgerungen draus ziehen könnte, jetzt abgesehen von der etablierten wissenschaftlichen Gemeinde, eben, na ja, mindestens knifflig bis unmöglich war. Wenn man jetzt so eine offene Strategie fährt, dann, da fällt mir so einiges ein. Vor allem, ich will das jetzt nicht zu sehr überhöhen, aber auch aus meiner Beobachtung der Dynamik, insbesondere das, was das Internet gebracht hat durch diesen freien Datenaustausch, wann auch immer irgendjemand einen großen Datensatz in diese Welt abgelassen hat mit den Bedingungen, die im Wesentlichen sind so, mach doch was ihr wollt, haben sich da innerhalb kürzester Zeit einfach Ideen draus entwickelt, die wahrscheinlich kaum irgendjemand vorher so gehabt hat. Gerade im Bereich Katagraphierung, ich hatte ja OpenStreetMap schon genannt, dürfte das auf jeden Fall sehr interessant sein, aber ich könnte mir eben auch vorstellen, dass solche Ansätze auch eine ganz andere Verankerung von Wissenschaft auf einmal etablieren, die ja bisher noch sehr, sagen wir mal, durch diesen akademischen Weg definiert ist. Trotzdem findet man eben insbesondere im Softwarebereich eben auch häufig Karrieren, die eben jetzt gar nicht so sehr durch so eine akademische Ausbildung initiiert wurden, sondern einfach weil da Talent ist, was sich einfach seinen Weg gesucht hat und durch den freien Zugang zu den Mitteln, zu den Netzen und eben auch zu den Daten an der Stelle eben Karrieren und eben dann auch letztlich Softwaresysteme und auch handfeste Ergebnisse erzielt hat, die so auch vor 20 Jahren nicht zu sehen waren. Ist das auch so ein bisschen so eine Kalkulation, dass man hier so einen, dem wissenschaftlichen Betrieb einen ganz neuen Spin gibt?
Es ist ganz richtig, wie du sagst. Vor 20 Jahren hat es die Möglichkeit nicht gegeben, dass man, dass einfach die Daten so frei herausgegeben werden konnten.
Allein schon von der Datenmenge her nicht.
Von der Datenmenge, aber es war auch eine andere Kultur. Damals waren Satellitendaten etwas ganz, ganz Wertvolles. Man hat ein Bild gekauft, man hat sich das eingerahmt, hat an die Wand gehängt und mit dem ein Jahr lang dran gearbeitet. Ich betreibe es ein bisschen, aber es war etwas ganz Rares. Auch dadurch, dass wir einfach viel mehr Daten sammeln heute, bekommen die Daten einen anderen Wert, intellektuell als auch materiell. Und das ist auf jeden Fall meine Einstellung. Ich glaube, man kann wesentlich mehr erreichen, wenn man die Daten einfach auf den Tisch wirft, auf den Markt wirft, unter die Leute wirft und sie damit spielen lässt und arbeiten lässt und kreative Dinge machen lässt, als wenn man die Daten versucht zu verkaufen oder einzusperren versucht und dann nicht genutzt irgendwo verstauben lässt. Also insofern ist das, glaube ich, vollkommen auch im Trend der Zeit, dass die Information einfach immer offener wird, transparenter wird. Zugang zu Information natürlich auch ein Element von Demokratie, sage ich mal. Wenn jemand weiß, was im Nachbarland oder in der Nachbargegend gemacht wird, was die Umweltinformation betrifft vor allem, erhöht das das Vertrauen und deshalb die Demokratie. Und das ist für mich ein ganz wichtiger Aspekt, auch der heutigen Zeit.
Ja, auch ein offener Wettbewerb der Methoden und Systematiken, die Vergleichbarkeit etc. Ja, Josef, haben wir es, würde ich sagen, oder? Das war ein sehr interessanter Einblick hier in die unmittelbare Zukunft der ESA. Bei Leib nicht das einzige in Planung befindliche Projekt, speichere die Raumfahrtmission der ESA, aber schon etwas, was schon eine besondere Bedeutung auch innerhalb der ESA hat. Nicht nur durch diese politische Konstellation, oder?
Das hat eine relativ große Bedeutung. Die ESA, also mit GMES, auch mit Galileo, aber GMES und Galileo sind eigentlich beide Projekte, wo wir unsere Arbeitsweise ändern, ziemlich ändern. Gerade in der Erbebeobachtung haben wir typischerweise, und ich habe selber damit gearbeitet, haben wir Daten einfach auf akademische Art und Weise ausgewertet und verwendet und nicht wirklich für den täglichen Nutzen bereitgestellt und verwendet. Und ich glaube, man muss hier einfach umdenken. Und man muss wirklich Systeme aufbauen, auch im Weltraumbereich, wo die Information mehr und mehr Teil des täglichen Informationsbedarfs wird. Und genau das versuchen wir mit GMES zu machen.
Vielen Dank und das war es, die 42. Ausgabe von Raumzeit. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Tschüss und bis bald.